[Musique]
bonjour à tous notre page GT vous
entraîne aujourd'hui au sud de la
Bourgogne tout près de Mâcon à la
découverte d'un site naturel
exceptionnel la roche de Vergisson alors
elle est moins connue que sa voisine à
La Roche de Solutré qui est fréquentée
elle par 200 000 visiteurs chaque année
mais c'est aussi ça qui fait son charme
[Musique]
bonjour ladina bonjour Maryline
bienvenue à Vergisson je crois que c'est
un nouveau coup de coeur dans la région
vous pouvez expliquer pourquoi alors
effectivement la roche de Vergisson
mérite d'être connue elle est souvent à
l'ombre de sa grande sœur solutrée mais
elle a beaucoup d'atouts beaucoup de
charme et de mystères notamment par son
histoire sa partie géologique son
panorama mais aussi par ses voies
d'escalade super on y va on la gravit
ensemble avec votre petite fille allez
c'est parti c'est parti
la balade n'est pas exigeante ladina
animatrice nature de métier a l'habitude
de guider des scolaires et des familles
sur ce promontoire un massif corallien
déserté par la mer et qui s'est formé il
y a environ 30 millions d'années au
moment du soulèvement des Alpes
il y a déjà un joli panorama ça commence
à causer petit bruit de fond mais bon
oui ça bosse dans les vignons
loin de l'engouement suscité par sa
jumelle solutrée vergissant offre le
sentiment d'être privilégié quand on
atteint ce magnifique balcon ah je
comprends pourquoi vous aimez bien
là le panorama de la roche de Vergisson
avec vue sur sa grande sorcelutrée donc
là pour un culminant
487 m et puis ce tapis de vigne à perte
de vue quoi et à l'automne ça fait
vraiment un patchwork de couleur ça vaut
le détour à l'automne aussi
une échappée belle dans une nature
sauvage qui recèle mille et un petit
trésors alors en termes de flore et les
riches parce que ce sont des pelouses
calcaires préservées ça permet à des
plantes comme des orchidées ou des
plantes assez fragiles de se développer
ici et également à des rapaces comme le
circaète avoir un super terrain de
chasse
[Musique]
Vergisson est également un haut lieu de
l'escalade l'aventure a commencé dans
les années 50-60 grâce à quelques
pionniers
elle se perpétue ce jour-là avec des
jeunes grimpeurs d'un club Maconnais
des fois c'est un petit peu engagé du
coup mentalement oui ça peut être
compliqué parce que quand même entre les
dégaines là il y avait deux trois mètres
je pense en moyenne
et ouais je suis content de l'avoir
refaite et après de 120 voix une grosse
centaine de voix sur verdisson donc il y
a largement de quoi les occuper un
certain temps
c'est un site où tous les niveaux sont
représentés du grimpeur débutant jusqu'à
jusqu'à l'expert donc c'est pour ça que
les gens se déplacent et viennent
jusqu'ici pour pour faire pour pratiquer
l'escalade
[Musique]
est aussi indissociable de la vigne il y
a ici 30 domaines et on retrouve tout de
suite l'un de ses professionnels bonjour
Pierre-Henri bonjour alors j'imagine que
vous avez quand même un cadre de travail
extraordinaire ça doit être plaisant
autour de nous c'est juste magnifique
quoi c'est souvent le dimanche je vais
avec mon chien sur la roche et c'est
vrai qu'on parlait détendu quoi c'est il
y a des millions d'années et nous on est
tout petit par rapport à ça et c'est
vrai qu'elle est là elle est résistante
et c'est un de nos éléments à nos
repères qu'on a enfin moi j'aime pour
moi qui suis né ici et qui est toujours
vécu moi je suis bien à l'ombre de ce
site naturel majestueux Pierre-Henri a
choisi de travailler ses vignes en
biodynamie je pense que c'est l'avenir
aussi de essayer de travailler de
manière à la plus logique et
intelligente possible dans un endroit
qui est merveilleux parce qu'on sait
qu'il y a du monde qui passe on vit
dedans
alors vous l'avez compris c'est un petit
paradis ici qu'il faut certes visiter
mais aussi protéger des outrages de
l'homme pour que ces vers de Lamartine
restent vraie le célèbre poète natif du
secteur décrivait ces deux escarpins
calcaires vergissons et solutrés comme
des navires pétrifiés surplombant une
mer de Vire